So now that we've combined
pulley A, string 2, platform,
and washer as our system, we
can now address our question.
If we measure the
acceleration of the person,
what is the force that the
person pulls the rope down
with?
Well, of course, that will just
be the tension in the string.
And with this simple
system, we can now
apply Newton's second
law, F equals ma.
But recall, we need
some directions.
So suppose we expect that the
acceleration of the platform
and person is up.
So we'll choose a unit vector j
hat in the positive direction.
And now the problem
becomes tension one,
three different tensions,
3T1, and gravitational force
minus mp plus mw times g.
Now, what is the mass
that we have to consider?
Again, what is the
mass of our system?
Well, the platform
and the person,
and we assume the pulley and
the string, too, were massless.
So we have simply mp plus mw a.
And so we can now solve for the
tension in the string, which
is equal to mp plus mw
times g plus a divided by 3.
And recall that this tension,
that the string is pulling,
this is what we called
the force that the person
[? of ?] the string
on the person.
And by Newton's
third law, that's
also, on the washer, that's
also the force that the washer
applies to string 1.
So this was our goal.
It's the force that
the washer applies
to string 1 by the third law.
And so by thinking about
how to choose a system, what
could be a very
complicated problem,
with lots of equations,
is simply one equation.